how long did it take you to write where
you felt you were writing at a
professional level hmm
probably five feature-length of
screenplays because it was my fifth spec
that actually was optioned and sold so
I'm like well I must be doing something
right so no but it took about in the
ones before were kind of bumbling and
there was you know it wasn't obviously
quite up to par to compete and those are
those are the ones that we see have to
get out of your system you know the
first two or three and a lot of many
times writers write their first script
and they're like where's my agent you
know this is grew their first script of
their first draft you know and say this
is brilliant and you're like well the
first of anything is not going to be
unless you're a genius which you very
well may be but most of the time there's
so many things that so many moving parts
you know that it's hard even at best to
get it like wow this is you know a
hundred percent there so it takes time
and so about the fifth one you know it
was about okay I think I've got this
under control you know and then you know
and then from that also that was a
learning experience to work with
producers because it's one thing to
write your script it's another - now
it's real you know where you don't live
in your bubble and you're like
everything's exactly the way I want and
you're like well now it's being taken
away from me and I have to compromise
and make changes and there's budgets and
all sorts of things you know and you
stick to you stick to the creative
aspects of it because you wrote it but
you have to realize that filmmaking is a
collaborative you know art form and
there's other people involved starts
with the script but a script is just a
script you know it's words on paper it
has to be brought elevated to actors and
someone to direct it and you know so I
think it's v my physics back and so not
just the fact that you were being hired
to do something but was it also the ease
or the the comfort in your own skin of
like okay I'm working with
and they may not like this and I'm gonna
get feedback and I'm gonna be okay with
that or what was there like something
that also shifted not just the fact that
you got these jobs was just huge but I
mean did you also feel like oh yeah okay
yeah this is I'm doing this yeah but
even now to a certain extent you know
there's still that with an artist I
don't think it ever goes away especially
writers where you're you know this voice
is going oh my gosh this is the one that
they find out your fraud you actually
were able to fool them you know 16 times
and now is the one where they catch you
you know but it's a constant learning
experience and I always say I get
butterflies before every job because I
respect as such and I don't take it for
granted so like oh this will be a walk
in the park or I know how to do this I
do but every time out is different every
scripts different every producers
different so it's not gonna be the same
as last time so you can't say well this
last one and some are easy and some are
just the worst thing ever
you know I'm hitting them I'm not saying
the worst thing ever but some are very
difficult and you just wonder like wow
how is it this one is so more so much
more difficult than the last that was a
breeze and you don't know I mean it's
it's just a weird combination of
elements you know and it's so but it's
better yes absolutely after I'm working
on my fortieth screenplay so I yeah but
I still like I say bow down to the craft
bin and respect it because I learned
something every time that I didn't know
before and I should be open to that I
think writers should be should be never
you get to a plateau and you're like I
know everything you know master martial
artist is is not only living it but also
continuing to learn you know so it's
like that kind of I keep using martial
arts because I'm studying right now a
little bit yeah so it's it's helpful in
the in the writing aspect philosophy of
almost the same thing because you know
the first moves are like let's not it
you have to do this now the pressure has
to be on that foot you keep but if
just keep at it you know and be open to
learning you know and with martial arts
would you say it's 50% physical 50%
mental I think well I'm not deep
intuitive but you know I've been
interested for many years but a lot of
it is mental and the physicality is you
can be a small person and still ward off
an attack because of what you know you
know what I mean it's it's using force
against its using you know against your
own you know what I mean it's like you
don't have to be Herculean person to
defend yourself but it's not about
defense you know I'm just saying but in
writing it's it's a discipline and I
think it should be followed as such and
it's a lifelong learning process so like
I say even after so many scripts some
are terrible some of the best I've ever
written and I I keep striving to have
the next one be better than the last one
and there are a lot of factors when it
ends up when you actually have a movie
that's filmed it's out of your control
you you write the script but you're not
there directing it you're not there
producing it there's a lot of there's a
lot of choices that can fall short from
what your vision of it becomes so at
that point you have to step back and
just go well on to the next one you know
and it doesn't mean you don't care but
you can't care so much that every time
you're just destroyed you know and
that's why I say about detachment is so
important over the long haul because it
doesn't mean you don't care and believe
me still I'm making changes now on a
script and I'm just like you know I care
but I have to get this thing through the
conveyor belt you know into the into
production so you know it's a lot less
stressful for you over the long haul to
care but just sort of be don't hang on
too tightly you know so that's just my
personal experience do you think going
back to the analogy of martial arts that
writing is similar 50% I wouldn't want
to say physical but the act of writing
and and you know and then the other 50%
is like this mental thing of showing up
every day not putting it off not going
to the beach and not letting the little
voice say this is horrible I'm not going
to finish this and and yeah yes and a
lot of us feel - you know writing is not
just mechanical there's a there's feel
like you're like you're sculpting you
know I think like with clay you know
you're writing a scene but your your
technique is through you know a laptop
or whatever you write on and it's coming
out here onto the page and so with that
it's a combination of all things mental
physical but also what we know it's it's
amazing because once when you feel and
you get a move right and you don't have
to think about it it's like you know and
you so how is this person to ever study
for so many years and do all these
different things because it just same
way of screenwriting how could you study
and know all these different things
because you just keep doing it again
again again you know and that's back to
your earlier comment about who's a
writer and who's not
if you're a writer you write you don't
talk about it you know Hemingway had a
quote about that the writers don't talk
about their stuff they're too busy
working and what I mean about that is
like oh I'm you know doing my pages and
this and that which is fine but you
better be doing the pages you're talking
about you know what I mean otherwise
it's just you're you and more talking
about your work than actually doing the
work it's always about the work so we
can talk about our work but if there is
no work that's real and I'm not saying
you have to sell something either you
know writers - right you're absolutely a
writer you know but if you if you find
that it's not for you that's okay -
because I see people come up against
that wall all the time and they're
fighting desperately sick you like oh
it's okay to let go if it's not right
for you why do you want to try to force
it
you know I mean kids along its
up-and-down journey to be a writer you
know so it's you that's why I would say
you have to really love it
more than anything else because it's
gonna be it's gonna break your heart and
it's going to be the the best thing
you've ever experienced in your life at
the same time